a decade on from his death the legacy of
pop megastar Michael Jackson remains
under threat from serious child abuse
allegations tomorrow night a documentary
called leaving Neverland will air on
channel 4 based around extended
interviews with two men who claim the
musician groomed and serially molested
them over a number of years Wade Robson
was seven when he first became close to
the star while James
safe Chuck met him aged nine this is a
clip from the explosive new film
everybody wanted to meet Michael or be
with Michael and you're just starstruck
and then he likes you he said you know
do you and the family do you guys want
to come to Neverland saw the big
seduction he was one of the kindest
people I knew and he also sexually
abused me I was seven seven years old we
had this mock wedding ceremony
I was with him there was abuse Michael
Jackson was acquitted of molestation
charges in 2005 his representatives
pointed out that both men in the
documentary previously testified that he
did nothing inappropriate to them will
join now by Michael Jackson's nephew Taj
who's going to talk in more detail about
this hi thanks for joining us on the
program really appreciate it what do you
wanna say it's been hard it's really
been hard because you know we knew Wayne
we knew Wade very well he dated my
cousin Brandi for over eight years and
so to see that turn of events you know
especially at the time he was you know
super close to us super close to my
uncle as well but we don't feel like our
voices being told because there's all
these headlines and headlines and so
it's been hard in that way what do you
wanna say just for the documentary I
wouldn't want to say just basically if
you have four hours to watch it just
please have like ten minutes just to do
a search to see because my uncle's are
no longer here so it doesn't matter
about credibility and character so just
take 10 minutes on Google and look up
credibility what credibility are you
questioning weight and general way and
what way well they've both changed their
story about three or four different
times in their deposition compared to
this movie you know why they've done
that though don't you and you know why
they've said that they've done that
which is that they are both now older
and their fathers and they felt under
pressure when they were giving their
evidence previously and now they feel
somewhat different because they've got
their own children and they feel that
they need to speak out I'm talking about
the 2016 deposition so it's more recent
because they said the estate for
hundreds of millions of dollars so that
has been consistent with it I'm not
talking about the 2055 sure although HBO
they're not being paid at all are they
for their contribution to this
documentary not by HBO but in terms of
because they have an appeal right now
with the estate in terms of them suing
so there's an appeal this year for them
there were other allegations about your
uncle they weren't there it's not just
these two over the years and more
has to wonder why a grown man would have
children having sleepovers yeah related
very first answer is you know it's the
hardest answer that I have to say
because I was you know in that
environment I was a kid as well but you
know it's hard for me to say a grown man
and you know my uncle was a child at
heart you know but he didn't have a
normal childhood and everyone that knew
him you know from Elizabeth Taylor to
Whoopi Goldberg to Macaulay Culkin the
ones that he let in they recognized that
and I think it's it's hard for me to say
because I know as a parent you know you
look at it differently you're like that
there's no way that that should happen
period but my uncle didn't have that
childhood and he would always ask us you
know what is it like to have birthday
parties or what is it like to just hang
out with your friends and simple stuff
like that he just didn't have and he
would kind of live vicariously through
us with that he couldn't even go to the
mall or to go to a movie without closing
the whole movie down that's a different
life than anyone else you know as should
he have been if he was a child at heart
sure do you know I've been better looked
after by the people who random to
protect him from himself
I you know I think so but at the same
time like even with like myself it's
like you see the pier like and it sounds
corny but you see the pureness of him
you see that he really doesn't have a
boat he doesn't have that in his system
and so you don't look at it that way I
think if you thought you know let me
keep an eye on this because this doesn't
look right this looks creepy then yes I
would have all alarms would have been
off on that wedding ritual with a
ten-year-old boy but that's James word
that's what my uncle's not here to
protect himself and so we have to go off
of their word that there's nothing to
say that he didn't make up that whole
thing and that's not we've seen the ring
now haven't really seen but that's what
I'm saying as well you know in terms of
he's bought me plenty of things he's
bought me plenty if he paid for my
education and so I could easily have sit
here and say the same thing I can say
when I take all these kids out on tour
with him it's just didn't he that was
how he had his childhood you know he
he liked that interpret and it wasn't
only boys you know there's plenty of
girls that he did that too
you know the that doesn't help no it
doesn't mean that's not a good defense
no it doesn't help but when you know I'm
just saying that it wasn't like oh it's
boys only I'm saying that in terms of
just childhood he just he was looking
for that companionship and not in a
sexual way just in a friendship way okay
where do you think why do you think all
these allegations come from because it's
not just these two guys is it there's
lots of other kids as well and families
that have made allegations and there are
suggestions that money has been paid to
families in order for them not to press
charges yeah there's a 1993 one yeah
that's the one that started it all
family Chandler yeah that one that was
for the civil case and that didn't that
never stopped Jordie from actually
testifying in a criminal case so
everyone that says oh he paid hush money
Jordie could have testified in 1994 he
could have testified in 2005 it was a it
was just that my uncle did not want to
fight a civil and a criminal case at the
same time which is now illegal I know
because when you do a civil case the
civil case should come after the
criminal because yes generally yeah
generally because it's almost like
seeing someone's playbooks that's we saw
with OJ Simpson yeah you you if you see
the PlayBook you know how to combat
everything so he was like I want to get
rid of one and I will fight the criminal
because that's the most important one
and then they held that they held it
open for about four four months don't
quote me on that it's four to five
months and they couldn't they didn't
have any evidence so they had to let it
go but it didn't stop him from
testifying and that's been a that's been
a myth that no one's combated because
our family doesn't like to talk about
those things but we're here kind of
defending my uncle's legacy you know
yeah how what impact did all his court
case and then all of these allegations
that we subsequently seen what impact
did they have on him as a person it
destroyed him I mean I lived with him at
Neverland during the trial
yeah you could see it you could see him
slowly wither away it it killed him it
really did because it was the one thing
he thought he was helping in the world
he thought he was helping people and
then to see someone on this
and talking about you in a certain way
it's probably the hardest thing you can
do and you can literally watch his
deterioration he never recovered from
that when these allegations started to
materialize not just these two but
others as well why didn't he realize
that it was appropriate for him to step
back and not to be involved with young
people yeah well 2005 that was the case
you know of it but Gavin was dying of
cancer basically and you know I asked
him that question he said I cannot let
him die I just could not let him die you
know because we stepped as a family we
were like you know this is how it looks
but at the same time he he was almost
like not on my watch I will not let that
happen and you know we saw what what the
repercussions were in that case but he
just could not do that and you know
Gavin right now is I'm not saying that
was my uncle saying but he's living a
life right now
you know without cancer how can you be
so sure touch that he didn't abuse any
of these kids you know that's you must
ask yourself that I always because
you're a dad yes well not only a dad I
mean you've been abuse over let's not
say who you think Rob vyas but yeah you
know you have been a victim yes of
sexual abuse yes you know
yeah I'm hypersensitive about that and I
think you know I always like to say you
know if you're a battered wife you can
kind of sense if you have a friend that
actually also has that symptom you know
you don't need them to come out and say
it you can just you're really hyper
sensitive to those things and you kind
of identify with it you're very close to
looking at the warning signs I can tell
you I've I've been around people where
I've just gotten that energy and it's
like it's an energy that you're like
that's a bad person I'll stay away from
them and I think you know if I ever felt
that way about my uncle just one hint of
it I wouldn't be here defending him I
wouldn't have flown you know from LA and
it's just it's not what I would have
done what impact is it having on his
children it's you know his youngest
child which everyone knows is blanket
but he goes by BG now he's he's horrible
right now he's not talking you know he's
the
school I mean I probably in trouble for
my family by saying this but I think
it's good to be honest he's uh the
teachers are worried about him because
he said what why because he's usually
talking to he's usually and he's just
he's internalizing he's come because
this is the hardest thing for him
because he wants to say something he
wants his dad's getting attacked and
he's not here to defend himself how
would you say not he's 17 now is he yeah
okay so this morning he's got he's got
that same heart that my uncle had and
you know that same sensitivity mm-hmm
what would you say to HBO about this
documentary I would just say you know
why didn't you want to get the other
side you know it's a one-sided
documentary if you're gonna do something
that serious with that big of an
allegation why did you not want to get
another side or talk to you know
Macaulay Culkin or Brett Barnes you know
why did you not do that that's all I
would say you know what do you want to
be able to achieve as a result of
putting yourself out there and defending
your uncle when you know many people who
are watching or say come on
or he's supposed to do this as his
family or yeah or you know the big
misconception oh they have something to
financially gain from it which we don't
his kids do their part of the estate I'm
not you know I think I'm doing what my
uncle would have done for me you know
when my mom passed my uncle was the
first one there you know to basically
catch me and I'm I feel almost honored
to do this in a way because he gave me
so much and it's like this is a little
least I can do
honest appreciate you taking it to you
thank you very much for a second not at
all we really appreciate you taking the
time thank you thanks